[Music]
the super powered umbrella academy
wouldn't be the same without some
seriously powerful vfx the team behind
the show put in some incredible work to
bring our favorite moments to the screen
number one
the epic finale of season two required a
lot of impressive vfx work you know
you're right let's change that when
handler summons 8 000 agents they are
almost entirely cgi doubles with only a
handful of them being real extras they
filmed on set to make this process even
more difficult it started snowing
halfway through their filming of the
scene so some of the extras that they
originally had didn't show up again
forcing the vfx team to fix continuity
issues via cgi when the agents charge
the house and then subsequently get
blasted those shots are almost
completely cgi as well with the
exception of a few small elements and
the house itself it was really really
complicated
how are they doing that
number two
pogo the chimp looked incredible and was
a testament to how talented the team at
what a digital is they were tasked with
creating this character and didn't shy
away from the challenge there is a
certain challenge in making something
subtly believable the vfx team knew how
important it was to create realistic
clothing for pogo so they actually
developed a new software specifically
for making the most realistic clothing
possible when it came time to filming
pogo scenes they actually used two
actors for different aspects of the
character's performance actor ken hall
was on set in a motion capture suit
interacting with other characters and
providing the body movements for pogo
meanwhile adam godly lent his voice to
the character does anyone wish to speak
and did so in a studio where they also
captured his facial performance to give
pogo the final touch of real emotion
number three
one of the most complex shots the bfx
team had to execute was when we see the
members of the umbrella academy all
dancing alone in their rooms they shot
the actors individually on green screen
and then placed them into the scene
which aside from the actors themselves
was a full cg animation what's more it
was the first day of shooting for many
of the cast members
i feel like we really had an energy
together that that worked
number four
when we first meet luther we see him
casually going about his day on the moon
it's no surprise they didn't actually
film on the moon but it may surprise you
that almost everything you see is cgi
actor tom hopper was filmed on a green
screen while being suspended with wires
to simulate the weightlessness of space
very few elements were practical and
most of the time the only real aspect is
luthor and a part of his spacesuit even
his helmet was cgi
number five the epic war scene at the
beginning of season two was brought to
life with a mix of impressive practical
set pieces and visually stunning cgi a
lot of the rubble and debris on the
ground was real while the buildings and
all the action happening in the sky was
cgi and that tank rolling down the
street that was real the shell shot out
of it was cg animation as was when vanya
stopped at mid-air elliot page was
lifted into the air on wires and shot on
a green screen to create the effect of
her character stopping the missile put
it all together and the result is an
epic scene
what the hell was that the end of the
world november 25th 1963.
number six
when you have a character that has a
humanoid body with a fishbowl head that
contains a real-life goldfish you have
to get creative in bringing said
character to life when filming they had
an actor wearing the suit and bottom
collar piece of the bowl we see in the
show with his head later being replaced
with a cgi fishbowl they did have a
fishbowl head on set for reference but
it was only on a stick and didn't
contain any water or fish what a digital
the studio behind the fish effects
bought real goldfish and kept them as
pets what a digital did a phenomenal job
making it happen
surely we can come to some form of
agreement that benefits both parties
number seven
when we see the commission's inner
workings we are introduced to an
infinite room of workers be a part of
something
[Music]
so grand that shows the massive scale of
the organization in real life the room
is much less impressive they shot the
scene in a small room with only a few
desk workers in front of a green screen
they expanded the size of the room with
cgi and added hundreds of more desk
workers to achieve the scale they were
going for
who was the case manager handling me
[Music]
number eight
when klaus summons his ghost friends you
can rest easy knowing they're not real
ghosts and are instead the work of cgi
artists in the season 1 finale and at
the beginning of season 2 ghost ben is
completely cgi and when ben is trying to
get out of klaus actor robert sheehan
was acting alongside no one and had to
do his best to pretend to be pushing a
ghost back into his body
we hope you enjoyed that as much as we
did
number nine
all of the jfk scenes in season two were
almost completely cgi in some of the
wide city shots the buildings motorcade
and even the people are cgi when vanya
destroys the fbi building elliot page
was on wires on a green screen set and
even then they were mostly replaced with
cgi anyway and when klaus tackles the
man with the umbrella the motorcade
behind him and all the people in the
background are cgi why use extras when
you have an amazing vfx team
number 10
reginald hargreaves revealing himself as
an alien is a shocking twist we didn't
see coming for the reveal they built a
mask that resembled kung fiore's face
and had the actor unzip it and peel it
off his head underneath the mask on his
real head he wore a motion capture cap
the cgi alien head was added later on to
complete the reveal
number 11
the effects team spent a lot of time
developing all the warp and wave effects
caused by the powers from the characters
five jumping through time allison's
powers and vania's blast waves all use
the same type of viscous effect vfx
supervisor everett burrell described the
effect as going into and coming out of a
bowl of jelly because of this the team
appropriately named the effect jelly
vision we use my ability to time travel
but this time
i'll take you with me number 12
the scenes with klaus and his cult
involved a mixture of practical and
digital effects the bus scenes were
filmed on a big blue screen with fans
used to simulate wind the city of
varanasi was added using cgi
number 13
a lot of cgi was used during the white
violin final battle in season 1. banya's
transformation into the white violin was
accomplished using bright lights on set
which were enhanced with a cgi glow that
was added in later the theater was at
times a real set and other times they
used a cgi version of it like when the
explosion comes through which was also a
cgi simulation
number 14
the epic shop was created with both
practical and digital effects they
filmed it on a giant outdoor set that
had a lot of real debris surrounding
actor aiden gallagher there was a small
green screen behind gallagher and the
rest of the environment was filled in
digitally
number 15
the unleashing of vania's powers for the
first time was a big moment for the
character elliot page was filmed alone
on a green screen while the camera
rotated around them the rain and the
environment were added digitally the
result was the first display of vania's
true powers
those were some high-powered vfx for a
high-powered super team which scene left
you most impressed with its vfx let us
know in the comments and thanks for
stopping by at the things